hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in the early chapters of book two of his
discourses
Epictetus is raising some very
interesting questions about the
compatibility or the incompatibility
certain let's call them either qualities
or compartments ways in which people
engage themselves or orient themselves
towards the world and also towards
themselves and their own engagement with
the world than with other people now the
terms that he's using our translated as
confidence
caution in care or concern confidence is
you know in the verb for it would be
soldering solder osseous is the feeling
and it means something like you know
walking in and feeling like everything's
okay you knowing how you're going to do
you're not worried about anything it's
the sort of thing that that is displayed
by you know animals for example when
they are rushing out to get their prey
or defending their job or things like
that matters
caution a lobby up or the verb a
lobbyist side literally what that means
is like taking a good
grasp on something but remember that the
stomachs use a lot of terms from that
verb of grasping my Bonnie for you no
mental acts or you might say perceptive
ants right how do we grasp things so
caution means are like you know getting
in there and looking around making sure
everything is the way it ought to be and
then the concern of people a oh you know
this is this is a term that was around
for quite a while as well when we talk
about you know the care of the self or
things like that is being part of
ancient philosophy is this term in its
cognate that we have in mind to give a
concern to to give care to to pay
attention to so the question then is
look stoicism teaches us that there's
two kinds of things those that are in
our control those that we have some
measure of control over because they
actually fall within the scope of our
Faculty of choice and then all those
things that are outside of our control
so should we ideally be trying to attain
a state where we're just not bothered by
anything and we can feel confident all
the time we certainly want to know what
I feel you know a sense of care or you
know caution towards external things
right because they're not that important
or are they well that's the question
here so epictetus is going to say these
qualities would be incompatible if we
were going to try the same person was
going to show them to the same thing at
the same time but in fact we need to be
displaying both of these towards
different things that we are
encountering including ourselves so
towards what falls within the scope of
our faculty choice that's where our
genuine good and a bad line right not in
these external things which are strictly
speaking in different then
say they don't have a positive or
negative value in themselves we've
walked it if he says yeah care and
concern and caution and if we don't were
really setting ourselves up for all
sorts of problems aren't we will get to
that in just a moment it's not my
contrast we should have a confidence
towards external things why because they
can't really hurt us so we can go into
any situation I'll say for example
performing right.we he's got a lot of
discussions about performers and they
get they're anxious about playing why
because they they're they're too
concerned with what the audience thinks
something they have no control
whatsoever about just be confident in
your own art and your skill go in there
play if your goal is to make good music
you can do that if your goal is to give
a good lecture you can do that if other
people applaud that's as we say the
icing on the cake or we often say that's
the gravy right but that's not something
that you need to be concerned with you
know we can have an attitude of
untroubled miss not only you know with
respect to our own stuff but things that
are other people's things that are the
world we can not be affected by them and
that that should be how we ought to
behave now if we try to do that globally
and we don't pay attention to our own
faculty of choice which doesn't start
out automatically choosing the right
things as a matter of fact is most
likely from the stoic perspective quite
damaged quite deformed by the time that
we begin to scrutinize it then we're
going to have all sorts of problems and
we're not going to even be able to be
confident about things that are external
to us because we're going to be valuing
them too much so you've got an example
here from from Chapter one of booktube
confidence towards death we should feel
confident in the face of death
why because death itself is not an evil
to us what we want to have caution about
is whether we're feeling
fear of death and then we have to think
why are we fearing death death is by
itself is not an evil it just says you
know it is different it is something
that is and it's our attitude towards it
that causes us so much anguish or
anxiety we can go on with all sorts of
other similar examples where you know
there is something there's some sort of
thing that presents itself to us and we
can be confident in relation to it and
we want to be confident the stoic to say
precisely because we take caution or
care about what it is that we ourselves
are thinking what it is that we are
making them it how are we feeling about
it how does it affect our desires and
aversions or we can find our desires and
aversions here or we are going to you
know straight out into the world where
they're going to get us into trouble a
little bit later on he will say in that
same chapter that it's precisely because
we take caution over here in the things
that we need to take caution and the
things that lie within the realm of our
moral purpose or a Faculty of choice are
probably racist that we then can feel
confidence towards the other things the
external things if we don't do that
we're not going to have that confidence
is a sustainable comportment he also
raises an interesting question about
care and concern should we exhibit any
sort of care or concern about these
externals we know we should have about
ourselves right we should pay attention
to what's going on on our hearts but
those external things do they need
really matter they're indifferent
morally so why do why can't they just be
careless with them if my bite doesn't
matter what does it you know if I leave
it out of the ring who's harmed by that
right the by it rusts it's not not a big
deal
well I pick Tina says it's not quite so
simple as that our uses of indifference
has a moral value
affects us so what would be in a
difference in different externals well
he gives us some examples actually quite
a few which are which are quite good he
says think about skillful ballplayers
none of them is concerned about the ball
as being something good or bad but about
throwing it and catching it accordingly
form has to do with that skill with that
and speed and grace where I cannot catch
the ball even if I spread out my cloak
the expert catches it if I throw you
know we can turn throw the ball on a
flurry or in fear what fun is there left
and how can a man be steadier see what
comes next in the game but one player
will say throw another don't throw and
yet another don't throw it up that
indeed would be a strength and not a
game Anthony says this is like Socrates
going into his lawsuit this is the suit
in which he actually would become
condemned to death he says he knew how
to play in the law court and what does
he mean by that well instead of being
concerned with how the game was going to
turn out he played the game he went into
this case confident knowing that he
doesn't control the jury and he was
going to tell the truth and he was going
to cross-examine his accuser and he was
going to make a case to the Athenian
people and he did right he used the
externals well and so Epictetus is
saying we need to have that sort of
attitude of care or attentiveness might
be another way of translated towards all
these things that are you know that we
have some measure of you know not
necessarily control over but at least
some determinative factor and he says
our externals to be used carelessly not
at all for this again is to the moral
purpose and evil and that's unnatural to
it they must be used carefully because
their use is not a matter of
indifference and at the same time with
steadfast
that's and peace of mind because the
material is indifferent so again we
should feel untroubled but also careful
even with respect to these external
things what happens if we get this wrong
well he gives us some great examples of
this yeah
chapter one he says when we're cautious
about the things that are really evil
the result will be that we have
confidence in regard to the things that
are not in that nature that's what
things are aligned right
however we act like deer when the hinds
are framed by the feathers and run away
from them where do they turn and to what
do they fly for refuge as a sacred tree
right into the Nets the hunters know
this that they can get the deer to run
into your traps matter of fact human
beings have been hunting species a sense
we've been not even civilized since we
began working together
we hunted species many of them to
extinction so he says so it is with us
also weird to be show fear and thousands
of things which lie outside the province
of the moral purpose again in which do
we behave with confidence as if there
were no danger in the things that
concern the moral purpose so many of us
have our priorities screwed up when it
comes to that were careless were
overconfident about how our you know
moral purpose how our character how the
fabric of our personality is being
improved or being destroyed and deformed
by their reactions and worried about
externals we allow ourselves to become
upset by them we allow our desires and
aversions to go around willy-nilly in
the world and draws along both of those
and get us into all sorts of troubles in
the sense of being disturb so I mean if
we if we want to have the proper
arrangement of these compartments this
is what it would look like for us by
paying attention
- are you know what is within what is
within the scope of our power what is
within ourselves we can have the right
attitude of confidence and also you know
care or concern for how we used
externals